good afternoon everyone
thank you for coming to my uh talk
presentation
and i see some familiar names in a
participant list
wow thank you for being here i see
someone who comes from the
same cohort was the boot camp so thanks
for being here
so this is an interesting zoom setting i
actually don't got to see your faces
um so i guess whenever you have
some questions um maybe we can
yeah we can use the chat yes
delighted to see you yes and delighted
to have all of you here joining me
today for the talk i definitely look
forward
uh to learning more from you because um
i'm very very new in using wall frame
but uh i've been a huge fan since i
joined
the warframe boot camp since last year
okay so i guess i'll get started
um it's 1 31 right now um
thank you all for being here today thank
you so very much
for joining my presentation um
[Music]
i trust what you can see now is the
presentation
so what i'm going to do here today is
i'm going to talk about
how ceos and cfos talk about the impact
of coronavirus shutdown
on corporate profits so um
my presentation i feel it will fit into
the category
of the warframe computational x which is
computational
accounting i say so i will i will do
this
as an accounting talk and then i will
add email to say how wolfram has
added value and help me conduct this
analysis of research question so let me
introduce the co-author
so davis is a middle school student at
countryside school
i would say that in this project i am
the
accounting part and davis provides the
coding brain
i'm very appreciative of what he did for
me here
okay i hope you will like um
the talk so what is the question i'm
doing here
i analyzed the earnings conference
called transcripts
in the quarter before and after the
covet lockdown i want to see
what is the compare and contrast there
what is the difference there
the sample for now it includes 30
companies the top 10 from cap
from health care and then from consumer
staples
so we use wolfram mathematica to analyze
the text length structure tone and
keywords
which i will show later are the five key
pattern changes
quarters before and after covert 19
lockdown
the first thing is companies begins to
shift
from the focus on numbers financial
numbers
to talk more about their staff their
partners their associate and their
people
so the first changes from members to
people
the second key change there is from
company products
and service to human needs so in
previous quarters companies are more
likely to talk about what they can do
and what they can deliver in this
quarter they are more likely to focus on
human needs and focus on how they can
tailor what they can deliver
to the human needs the third thing which
i feel is very interesting is company
um shift from saying how prideful they
are
with are delivering shareholder value to
how grateful they are
in how they can still be helpful to
people and stay in business
in such a difficult time the fourth
changes
there is a very significant change that
ceo and cfos when they answer questions
they shift the focus from the current
quarter to the long horizon which is
understandable because in the near term
there's going to be a lot of
uncertainties the fixed change which is
communicational uh
communication strategy thing that is
used by ceos and cfos in this quarter
is they shift from the prevention focus
to promotion
focus it's a very interesting um shift
we'll talk more um in a minute
so during the talk um whenever you have
questions
feel free to put that in the chat box i
plan to finish this
within 20 minutes and i hope that we can
have a lot of time
to talk and have some q a session
also um i will have a i will have two
very specific questions that i want to
ask for help
from the expertise in wolfram team
regarding
the future plan for this study and how
often can help me better understand and
investigate my research questions
why am i interested in this study
now it's definitely a looming
uh earnings season uh it fell short of
analysts
expectations and people don't really
know what's going on there
and we know that accounting numbers
matter accounting number have a very
high predictive power
and explains the variation in terms of
company
uh stock uh price so it's a very very
important um um document to analyze
when it comes to earnings now in
addition to that right
now there are like quarterly and annual
reports
that are um disclosed at the end of
quarter and at the end of the fiscal
year but these are not
as timely as earnings conference costs
so what are earnings conference costs
this is the target test that i used to
analyze in my
talk today and in this study it
definitely is
more timely disclosure than quarterly
report and annual report it also boils
down earnings information into an easily
digestible form now in terms of
structure what are going to expect
during these earnings conference calls
the first part is that ceo and cfos do
their
prepared remarks your presentation and
after that
the ir director is going to signal to
the analysts who participant
and say now we started q a and that
analyst the one asked questions
there's an answer and this continues
usually there are
a dozen uh analysts coming to these
earnings conference calls and they ask
um 10 to 20 questions so that's what's
uh expected there that's the target text
okay so there are several interesting
descriptors
right when i try to use warframe
warframe does have a very
a powerful textural analysis
and visualization to help me with
generating
some descriptive analysis right so for
each of these
descriptive analysis i'm going to post
this
on either cloud or unpassable so you can
get to see this after my presentation if
you're more interested
basically in this presentation slides i
include all the visualizations
related to the descriptives that i
provide
but these are not the focus of the study
so i'm just going to go through them
very briefly the tax length of these
earnings conference costs did not change
significantly there is like a nine to
ten percent
increase but it's not a big deal the
duration also increases
which is understandable if these texts
get longer
and in addition to that a very
interesting um
phenomenon there is the number of
participants in the earnings conference
cost during the covalent quarter it
actually drops a little bit
and of course all these are just
automatically generated
by wolfgang based on some coding right
now in addition to that right if i want
to do
analysis based on the um covert
19 quarter right so some of the basic
stuff i got to do is for example
the frequency of some keywords right and
for example this would be something
that's very um
intuitive to see and not quite
surprising that is last quarter nobody
really talked about cobit
but this quarter on average people talk
about
20 times in technology sector 32 taxing
consumer stable sector and 52 times in
healthcare and yes warframe has a very
good and intuitive way in generating
these numbers
now in addition to that in addition to
that the baseline
um hypothesis there is take a look at
these
negative words and positive words
uncertainty words and
certainty words now very interestingly
right
very interestingly for the earnings
quarter
for the covet quarter both negative
words
increases from previous quarter to
current quarter
and the use of positive words also
increased
slightly from last quarter to this
quarter now in addition to that
another interesting baseline finding
which again is not that surprising
is you can see that the uncertainty
words is more frequently used
in the covet quarter right we can see
for tech
consumer and healthcare there's increase
there
now the use of certainty words decreases
slightly for 10 quarter more for
consumer
and also for healthcare right so there
is some
these are just some backgrounds um and
descriptives
that are intuitive and not that
surprising
so um the code how to get the data
how to delete the wrapper test how to
find the text length
the participant's duration and the words
so i include
these um i include um
the code in here in case you want to
give it a run
um for now i'll just skip this part
not really a coding brain so yeah
yes the key findings that i want to talk
about here
to start with right um
the um typical opening in the previous
quarters
before the cold bit people usually start
with a financial overview on sales they
will say something that we have a solid
quarter we're proud
we have growth demand we mentioned
technology product
that's by region by segment etc in the
third paragraph we'll talk about the
revenue
growth margin um the expenses cash and
dividend
in this quarter every one shift and
there is
another type of structure in this tax
role
for the conference called transcript
people
start the financial overview not on
numbers but on people
most of the time will observe a very
typical structure
they say it's a challenging moment we
are very grateful
it's our privilege to help people at
this moment technologies like this and
that
is being used to fight the disease at
all
and we are very grateful to work with
these people and the health and safety
of the men
and women we work with is the highest
priority for us
the last paragraph in this opening um in
this typical opening in earnings
conference call would be we learn
observe we emerge even stronger we are
confident about the long horizon future
so warframe is very nice in providing in
providing um
the manipulate function in which i can
easily
show if i have a um
let's say a word list that i tell
warframe to use right for example
if i'm interested to know um words that
are related to
gratitude then i can use this manipulate
function
to generate for me what are the words
related to appreciate
to grateful etc etc and also get me a
word account there
which is a good function now another
very interesting pattern that we observe
is in previous quarter people focus
more on financial numbers right that is
what analysts
expect them to deliver that is how they
are held accountable
in the capital market in this quarter
things have changed significantly
now if we look at the increase in the
use of the frequency of the words that
are related to employees
and are related to stakeholders we see
that
there is a significant increase for the
sector such as consumer staples
and for technology and also
for health care as well okay
similarly in this graph we see that
there
is an increase in the word use of
stakeholders
for example partners users developers
etc etc
and warframe can provide some very good
visualizations
for quickly seeing um how the
change of the words um is there
another very interesting change right
which is not a baseline finding is
um people now instead of talking about
how cool their product
is and how awesome their service are
they begin to try to
emphasize how they can use company
products and service
to help with the human needs right
what on human needs basically is the way
that we work
and also it's the way that we leave
right for example
when png procter gamble talk about their
home
products they say something like our
products clean your laundry your home
your hair
etc etc and interestingly even when they
talk about
the um influence of coronavirus they try
to
link this to the human need during the
remote
work and learning period for example
they say
when the png ceo is asked to explain why
the grooming product
has um have seen the drop in the sales
they say
well the challenge is lower shave
frequency which
while we're working from home to put it
monthly so we see
these kind of quotes from time to time
and
it's very interesting that instead of
just focusing on new technology and the
cool products that companies have
that they can deliver instead of
focusing on what they can do
they focus on what consumers need so the
shift from new tech to human needs a
very interesting trend
okay the fourth thing which again it
can it's something that's doable using
wolfram language analysis that is
we can easily after selecting a word
list
i can see that especially in the q a
session people now focus
more on long horizon even if
the analysts ask a question about the
current quarter ceos and cfos will
quickly shift the focus
from the current quarter where we can
deliver to how confident we are and
we are we have good faith we are forward
looking in the long horizon
okay so for example
something from coca-cola and i see some
i see that in the conference there is
also an
attendee from coca-cola is this uh quote
from james quincy
in times when a crisis has hit it can be
easy to lose sight of the long term
for the future as it has always done in
every previous
crisis for uh it's um 134 years
so this answer is given to an analyst
when alice asking something related to
advertisement expenditure and the
short-term drop
the ceo quickly changed the focus from
the short term
to the long run so that's the force
change i notice
number five which is an interesting
thing is
well what is the prevention what is
promotion
so the prevention focus is you focus on
how you can prevent
a loss the promotional focus is you
focus on how you can expand how you can
grow
how you can help others how you can
monetize right
so one very interesting disclosure
strategy is instead of using these
positive words saying that
how does the prices affect this and
affect that
the ceos and cfos when they're talking
about the changes
and their company's um performance
they would usually just try to be very
promotion-focused and say how our
products and service
can help customers meet urgent need
respond to the crisis and how our
business process are going to be
restructured
and flexible enough adaptive enough to
the new way of
working and leaving right so that's a
very very interesting
uh trend that i noticed so um
it's not surprising that when the
analysts
ask the um question
in the promotion focus the ceo answers
them in a promotion focus right how do
you grow
we plan to grow this way and it's also
very interesting that
even when analysts are asking these
questions with a preventive
focus saying how you can prevent the
loss
you have some issues you have some
disruptions
and there is expenses how do you plan to
to to deal with this now a very
interesting pattern that i can see in
this text
is that the um
the ceos and cfos they would shift the
focus from the prevention focus to the
promotion
even though they are asked in a
challenging way
and interestingly if people don't
quickly shift
their focus from prevention uh to
promotion
then um giving a prevention-focused
question would lead
to more challenges from alice regarding
the expenditure the cost uh many
expenses that you face right
so this is another interesting strategy
um disclosure strategy that we see
in this um in this um in this quarter
right after the clover right so these
are
the patterns um i will have two minutes
which is lead me to my conclusion
and also uh the questions that i need
your help for
okay um i'm very new in mathematica i
did a warframe bootcamp
in oh i begin to lost track of time
last year yeah last year august i'm very
grateful to
know a lot of people inside wolfram the
people who
left with a very warm impression on my
heart including danielle
ian a burrito which is a really good
teacher in the
boot camp and kevin mistral kevin
continues to help me with warframe and
he also co-teaches
some accounting sessions in my graduate
class in
university of illinois with me i feel
this is a great community
here are my questions um well
in terms of textual analysis right my
typical working process
is i read the text and then i took pages
of notes
now based on my understanding of the
previous quarters
and based on my understanding of other
financial statements i began to form
ideas right i begin to see what are
uh abnormal in this specific quarter i
form some hypotheses
i use warframe to find the supporting
evidence based on
the specific keywords i tell it and the
specific search pattern
that i tell um right for example more
frequently use of words related to
specific
um to specific category in the specific
quarter
now here is what i envision warframe
might be able to do
uh maybe it can already do that it's
just my own ignorance
that um that i can do i do not um have a
good command of the programming so i
don't yet no
what if i just feed the warframe with
text
like um i can i can ask warframe some
questions
for example i can i can feed wolfram
with several texts and then i can
automatically generate
the deviation in text links from the
baseline
do you recognize any variation in tones
the similarity with the last quarter
any change in the participants names
right
now um it will be really helpful for
researchers like me
if more processes could be automated
i'm pretty fortunate that in my home
there is someone who is really good at
wolfram language that can help me
but if warfarin can do more automated
tasks for behavior social science
finance and accounting researchers will
be super helpful
another question that i have um wolfram
gets me very good statistics about
keywords and search patterns
i want to ask for more for example more
ambiguous matching
um the analysis based on not just a word
or a um but word clusters
sentence paragraphs and the natural
meanings etc
um i am myself and i'm pretty ambiguous
in asking the question but maybe wolfram
can provide some
magical answer so um i'd love to hear
your comments on your advice
i feel this is a this is a very exciting
presentation for me uh i hope you guys
don't feel that is just too
accounting and not coding enough um
and i look forward um to talk more
with you if you are interested in
getting to more
about what we're doing here my email
address is listed here
and i will also post this presentation
slides
um either to wolfram cloud or to
passable so that is available
thank you so much for being here with
that being said i'd like to turn the
floor to the attendees
and see if you have any questions for me
oh what was the source of learnings
called transcript
um and was the study
published somewhere okay let me go ahead
and share my screen again so that we can
take a look
at the coding part
so how do we do this in warframe right
now
um there are a lot of sources for
company conference called
transcripts and um um we can go to the
sec website to download this another
easy way
is just to go to the full.com or
seekingalpha.com
these are investment advisory firms that
provide
free access for the earnings conference
call transcript
the reason why i choose full.com is that
it has a really nice structure for all
the earnings conference called transport
so that i can change some of these
parameters here
which would automatically get me the um
which would automatically get me to the
uh
transcript that i need right for example
here i'm just using one example
in the study that i did um it was 30
companies
for four consecutive quarters and we
we're now expanding it to
sp 500 companies for the last 10 years
to see what would be disclosure strategy
change
when um when there are other crises for
example financial crisis
or for example the hurricane such as
um the natural disasters right so this
is how we
get the transcript what does it look
like
right so by just getting
yes
yes so by um just um getting
the starting point and uh um
and the ending point of this text we can
easily just get to the
all of the text of the um earnings
conference called transcript and these
are readily available for the listed
companies in the united states
right let's scroll down this um we'll
see that
later on just by writing this is the
part that i feel warframe is so amazing
for example here right if i just simply
run
um this um and
by adding a little bit matrix vector to
the code that i'm doing
then i can automatically get the
length of the earnings conference called
transcript the duration
the co-participants the number of
participants
very nicely in a good structure that can
be easily
um either i use later use
the usual software that i use for
statistical analysis
and for visualization
okay and
sorry i think i did something wrong this
should not be
microsoft right and
this is another amazing thing i feel
it's a very useful teaching tool and
also research too
for myself when i'm doing the reading
notes right so if i am
interested to know what they talk about
uh when companies say
about covet right it would be so hard to
scroll
in this document and use the control f
by this manipulative function i can
easily just go to
the things that i want to know for
example what they talk about when it
comes to social distancing
right so that would be the code
accommodated words
i can also do something for example
related to
this i give did i run
set directory to notebook
the way that i do this is
um low-grand and mcdonald these are two
finance professors they have they have
very good uh
sentiment words list that are just
related to finance and accounting
and they provided publicly available um
you can download this from their website
and um by using the
existing word list and the word
dictionary that work for your specific
domain
maybe it's different from law accounting
finance uh
negative has a different meaning so in
general we don't talk about
for example collateral it may mean a
negative tone
in some domain bernina county is totally
a neutral
and so different words mean different
things in different domains
and so this is a domain specific
dictionary that i can take advantage of
and again using the wolfram manipulate
function
i can easily generate these um
these word list yeah so that's something
related to the
code was this study published
no it's not um i did a webinar in these
using this talk this is a fun project
for me and davis um during the cove
covert 19 lockdown so i
thought it would be very interesting to
see how i can use warframe
to help me automate the processing of a
lot of the text
in the finance and accounting disclosure
right for example earnings conference
cost
for example for example
the the annual report for example
the company a volunteer disclosure that
is the twitter
the social media um and also company
website that's a great source of
the um accounting this quotient
um and the textual analysis is
definitely not constrained
it's definitely not constrained to
numbers right so text images
audios videos these are
important content for investors and also
the capital market information
intermediaries such as
the banks and analysts to understand
what's going on there
so um i feel warframe has a great
a great uh value there i'm i'm
trying to i'm introducing i i started
teaching wolverine language in my data
analytics course
for managerial decision making at
university of illinois it's a graduate
class
um i feel there are some learning curve
that students need to face
initially but i just feel this is a
great this is a lot of
um thing that warframe can offer in
terms of um
helping students in social science
in economics in accounting and finance
in
improving their data analytic skills
um this is now it's uh
let's see whether there are any other
questions i'm going to refresh this
and see
oh i got another question i got another
question
asking uh my co-author if he is using
wolfram technology in his school
i wish they they would it's such a
good tool for kids to learn
math and to learn um how to
deal with this world right how to do
some computation
and how to how to begin to use these
two as a tool to test their own
hypothesis
for example like davis is working on
something related to
how to use warframe uh language to
calculate
the probability that my vote matters in
the state of illinois
in the presidential um election in the
year 2020 you just feel
that having warframe available for
middle school students
opens uh many many doors for them
in terms of their imagination and what
they can do
[Music]
thank you so much for all these great
questions
and i also see someone saying uh
that rohit says that um
helping someone with similar analysis on
temporary findings
maybe yes i'd love you oh youtube
contact
me via email please do that please do
that thank you so much
i have my
email address um typed impassable
and also here
also here um to to the zoom settings
uh it's um a bit past two and
that will be the end of my presentation
i'm so thankful for you being here
for your kind words and also for your
support
i look forward to talking with you
later on related topics or shared
interests thank you so much
you